what it's done so far is Consolidated
his base I mean he did joke a couple of
weeks ago I just need one more
indictment and I'll be unbeatable in the
Republican the race of the Republican
nomination well he's got his indictment
and he does look unbeatable I must say
he does look unbeatable for the
Republican nomination uh all these
indictments seem just to reinforce the
base that what he calls the Deep state
is out to get him and he says they're
coming for me now but if we don't win
this they're coming for you he says to
his base and they lap it up and it's
been a disaster for the other candidates
the DeSantis campaign governor of
Florida thought to be the only real
Challenger to Mr Trump his campaign is a
mess now going nowhere he's fired some
people he's having to reboot it you